äpfel aus südtirol rote bäckchen knackig
wohlschmeckend so wünscht sie der
verbraucher am besten an gebaut ohne
chemisch synthetische pestizide toni
riegler macht dass er gehört zu den
zwölf prozent bio bauern hat den betrieb
von seinem vater übernommen und schon
vor jahren auf öko umgestellt und der
hat sich in den jahren sehr gut
entwickelt
ich halte es einfach fasziniert dass es
möglich ist mit weniger chemie einsatz
und mit mehr einbinden der natürlichen
prozesse 950.000 tonnen äpfel werden in
südtirol jährlich geerntet knapp 90
prozent aus sogenannten integrierten
anbau unter massiven einsatz von
pestiziden sechs mal mehr als in der
italienischen landwirtschaft üblich noch
im jahr 2017 spritzen südtiroler bauern
pflanzenschutzmittel die in deutschland
bereits verboten waren
wir treffen landesrat schule auch er
baut äpfel annimmt die bauern in schutz
so schlimm sei das nicht mit den
pestiziden
dh dass man einmal bis auf bestimmte
pflanzenschutzmittel freiwillig
verzichtet zum anderen eben auch dass
man jeden einsatz entsprechender
rechtfertigen muss und somit auch der
einsatz von pflanzenschutzmitteln immer
mehr zurückgefahren wurde
das reicht vielen italienischen biobauer
nicht gemeinsam mit deutschen
umweltschützern fordern sie seit jahren
den völligen verzicht auf chemisch
synthetische pestizide design nicht nur
ein problem für die biobauern sondern
erst recht für die gesundheit vieler
menschen
es ist so dass tatsächlich das was die
bauern hier machen alles legal ist und
dass die eu in ihren zulassungsverfahren
diese mittel zulässt aber weder das
zulassungsverfahren noch das recht
schützt die bauern davon dass die kritik
daran üben dass sie in der
lebensmittelproduktion gift einsetzen
von gift will landesrat schuler nichts
hören er hat 1600 landwirte
zusammengetrommelt um gegen seine
kritiker vorzugehen
uns ging es darum irgendwo grenzen
aufzuzeigen
die rote linie aufzuzeigen die man
einfach nicht überschreiten darf es
braucht man auch im landwirtschaft
weiter zu entwickeln
auch die kritische haltung der
gesellschaft das ist alles in ordnung
aber es muss einfach diese kritik auch
respektvoll sein respekt verschaffen
will sich landesrat schüler vor gericht
er hat klage eingereicht wirft den
umweltschützern verleumdung und üble
nachrede vor wenigen tagen begann in
bozen der prozess als wir wirklich
realisiert hat nach dem ersten treffen
mit meinem jetzigen anwalt was auf uns
zukommt diese horrenden schadenersatz
drohungen
das hat tatsächlich auch eine haftstrafe
möglich ist da am ist das ein ziemlicher
schock gewesen
neben bär soll sich auch alexander
schiebe vor gericht verantworten wegen
verleumdung
der journalist hat ein buch über den
pestizid streit verfasst und teilt mit
saftiger polemik gegen die bauern aus
zitat tötung durch vorsätzliches
ignorieren der gefahren das sei nicht
ohne folgen geblieben man hatten alle
aufträge die ich im land südtirol hatte
sofort storniert man hat zunächst mal
versucht mich wirtschaft nicht zu
ruinieren
ich bin auch privat und mit meiner
familie ich habe hier fünf jahre gelebt
bedroht worden ich möge nicht mehr auf
den dorfplatz kommen wenn mir die
sicherheit meiner kinder etwas bedeutet
von solchen bedrohung hat der landesrat
nichts gehört dass die bauern aber
wütend sind hält er für nachvollziehbar
wenn man bäuerinnen und bauern auf diese
art und weise angreift da muss man auch
dann muss man ihn auch das recht
zugestehen wie in anderen bürger auch
sich einsparen
zur wehr zu setzen 50 kilometer weiter
wird auch über pestizide gestritten
im idyllischen vinschgau wollen viele
bürger keine apfel monokulturen
rund um die kleine stadt malz sollte
eine pestizidfreie zone entstehen
bürgermeister ulrich veith organisierte
ein bürgerbegehren
dabei unterstützte ihn das
umweltinstitut münchen
75 prozent der bürger stimmten für eine
pestizidfreie region
doch dann wird bald vor gericht gezerrt
bauern erheben klage der bürgermeister
habe seine kompetenzen weit
überschritten
ich war das blaue hat gedacht wenn wenn
sie es eine bevölkerung oder eine
gemeinde so deutlich für seinen weg aus
sticht dann ist es doch ganz klar dass
man diesen weg gehen darf hat dann aber
gesehen dass es nicht so ist wir haben
dann in einem nest bewegt wo dann die
meisten ziemlich aggressiv wurden nach
jahrelangem rechtsstreit musterfall das
projekt pestizidfrei region zurücknehmen
zur enttäuschung von biobauern wie
alexander edler seine kühe liefern milch
für bio käse und der muss 100 prozent
pestizidfrei sein
wir sind eines der sonnigsten taylor der
alpen aber auch eben auch eines der wind
reichsten taylor der halben und insofern
haben wir ständig das problem dass
chemische substanzen die auf nachbarn
flächen verwendet werden nicht dort
bleiben sondern eben auch auf
randflächen gelangen
und das ist unser problem ständig würden
die apfelplantagen erweitert und dadurch
noch mehr pestizide versprüht viele bio
bauern fühlen sich bedroht zum beispiel
die kudos sie bauen öko kräuter an
eigentlich ein gutes geschäft doch auch
für ihre produkte gilt 0-rückstand wir
haben eine wasserwand errichtet wir
haben acht meter hohe hacken gibt und
immer noch zu wenig wir haben die ganzen
felder mit folien tunnels überdacht wir
haben eine investition gemacht von
ungefähr zu sagen 200.000 euro um uns zu
schützen vor pestiziden von außen
dennoch mussten die glut ross manchmal
belastete produkte aus dem verkehr
ziehen jetzt pflanzen sie einen teil
ihrer kreuther weit weg von den
apfelplantagen an höher gelegen
dort wo bislang kaum obst angebaut wird
zurück nach bozen
vor gericht ist landesrat schuler nicht
erschienen
dabei hatte er kurz zuvor angekündigt
die klage gegen die umweltschützer
zurückzuziehen
doch seine anwälte haben keine vollmacht
der prozess muss vertagt werden
für die anwältin der umweltschützer eine
bewusste strategie um ihre mandanten
mürbe zu machen
jeder gerichtsprozess stellt für den
angeklagten eine große belastung dar
denn zum einen bringt so ein verfahren
viele kosten mit sich und zum anderen
werden die beklagten oft mit schmutz
beworfen der haften bleibt egal wie der
prozess ausgeht
am 27 november wird der prozess
fortgesetzt
inzwischen hat die staatsanwaltschaft
bei 1300 apfelbauern die betriebs bücher
beschlagnahmt
die dokumente sollen zeigen wie viel
pestizide tatsächlich gespritzt werden
für eine südtiroler apfel